Another key resource are people.
We sometimes use the fancy word of human resources or HR
and I kind of think of people in a start up as two separate categories.
One is finding qualified employees. The other is for you to find them.
How do you find mentors or teachers or coaches or advisers for you.
What's the difference between all of these?
Well let me start with the last first.
Mentors, teachers, and coaches advance your personal career.
If you want to learn a specific subject you find a teacher
but if you want to hone specific skills or reach an exact goal, I suggest you hire a coach.
That is a specific subject as a teacher, specific skills as a coach.
So for example if you want to learn something more about ??? architectures,
You can bring in a teacher or take a class
but if you want to hone specific skills like how to create great presentation
or how to manage people, you hire a coach but the one that sometimes founders forget
is that you want to get smarter, better over your career.
You want to find someone who cares enough about you to be a mentor.
Mentors are very different from teachers and coaches.
Mentors are actually a two way street.
The only people who tend to want to help you are those who personally think
they could actually learn something from you and then they simply liking you.
So most of you in your career would have to go on to be mentors
but think about the type of people who you've encountered in your career.
Implicitly you have been giving something to them while they have been giving something to you.
The last category in mentors, coaches, teachers are advisers.
Now advisers are people you need to help advance your company success.
Mentors, teachers, and coaches know about your personal success as a founder
but advisers really kind of bring generic advise.
Sometimes to you but also to your VPs and your staff etc.
So what you want to have is experienced advise
to help you figure out whether your vision is a hallucination
but getting specific you want to put together as early as possible an advise report
and that's really the idea of expanding your circle of accumulated wisdom as just your investment.
A mistake that founders make the first time is thinking that ??? or ??? investors ???.
Yes they are your advisers but they are also your boss
and so you want to be very careful about limiting your advise to just that circle
and they may not have this specific domain expertise you need.
So make sure you're expanding your series of advisers available to your company
and typically that's done by offering them a small percentage of equity
in exchange for some of their time.